what I want to point out before I move
any further it is a crucial piece is
missing from here I'll put out a couple
of things number one you are four
satellites here right X minus two x plus
one on the numerator X plus three X
minus one on the nominator so you can
see I've got more orange lines okay when
you look at your orange lines because
each one has a changing sign when each
one is zero if something happens you can
sound weird but where the factor is zero
nothing
never happens something has to take
place for example they need to see X
plus 3 X minus 1
those are on the denominator right so
when these factors are zero what happens
to the entire motion it does Forex so
therefore you get a very low center
right on the other hand it can look at
these factors at the top when they're
zero you get active don't you get
something else it's important you get
intercepts right that's why I think have
a look how to look at how I've drawn one
two three four spots when the factors
become zero right these two the ones
that become vertical asymptotes these
two are the ones that become intercepts
so you got all that behavior there I've
got my vertical asymptotes I don't have
all my acetones don't I make you missing
your horizontal asymptotes now again
you're so used to looking at once or
it's like y equals 0 y equals 0 it comes
up as a horizontal asymptote like 80 and
90% of time it's very very common but
this one isn't one of them ok
think you get about your limits forget
about what happened as X gets really
really big when X approaches infinity
how important are these numbers here
negative 2 a negative 3 they are not
important at all we call it trivial okay
now you would think that are these guys
here are more important than the
negative to the negative 3
they are more important but when you
compare them to these guys these like it
800-pound gorilla in the room okay
x-squared are really the guys who are in
the driver's seat
my tan x/2 actually grow but nothing in
comparison to these guys so these are
the really important one many other ones
that really matter in relation to each
other how quickly are they growing and
exactly the same rate one to one so as X
approached the affinity you're going to
get like a billion over a billion a
billion over a billion over do whatever
okay you can save it on top of the
bottom so therefore your horizontal
aperture between y equals one so go
ahead and draw that guy in now while I
draw that in I want you to notice this
weird interaction between the horizontal
asymptote and the region's
what do the region's tell you one of the
regions about they are about positive
and negative they're about sign right so
therefore you get this weird section
over here you shaded above the x-axis
but you shaded below the asymptote
because the attitude not a zero anymore
like was your I should say it's a y
equals one so therefore you've got this
kind of behavior okay now we're ready
I'm pretty sure I've got all of my
features drawn in about missing anyway I
don't wait is it of course
when x equals zero what do you get
two-thirds so you've noticed I've got
that being one so two-thirds better be a
bit below that right so I'll check that
guy is there okay I would ready to draw
this thing over on the Left what's
happening you're going to get that we
know sort of two fenced in going going
here
cool let's go from left to right you can
see I've got this approaching down here
behavior down in this corner right I've
got this approaching up here behavior
and in between I've got B to said that I
must plug through so therefore the only
shape I can think of that does that
looks kind of like that that you
your imagination magnet so you can see
our past through the records at spots I
obey the regions and I am approaching
the attitudes that's the only thing you
can possibly do finally on the right
hand side of you again have a sort of
hyperbole shape like ER with one little
difference
you've got to intercept as well that's
the beauty just sort of moves it up so
can you see your left hand and right
hand sides a kind of kind of sort of
variant from each other it's just that
this bit looks different because you've
got part of it costing through the axis
that's why you wanted to step in between
so you're so negative vibes you notice
that this shape is actually remarkably
similar let's go back to this shape it's
just sort of facing in the opposite
direction and you just got each SS in
different spots that's all
yep the happy notes that there's
anything advance that okay so good
question um and this question is
actually developed for both so the
question was you'll notice I'm
approaching this happen to hear from
above and I appreciate that Apple took
over there from the lower so why why is
it something like that or like that why
doesn't it do that turning thing that
we've seen before
okay now before I give you the answer I
want you to think carefully
the horizontal asymptotes where do they
come from again it come from limits like
that it comes from literally I can use
limits to help me here as well is it
carefully if I would actually take some
numbers let's have a look at this here
we go okay what's thinking about it over
like say x equals 100x equals not a
group going to be a link it all good but
I'm going to get a result out of here
that's beautiful I can take X equal
hundred I can put it here right why
should you help me work this out this
top thing here is going to make 10,000
minus
should stuff
the denoted a on the other hand is going
to be 10,000 plus some stuff do you
agree I don't really care what the stuff
is it's just little little little pieces
that aren't that prescription so which
is going to be bigger the numerator or
the denominator the denominator going to
bigger now if you've got a number where
the denominator is bigger then what does
that mean about the number in relation
to one just below just four right
doesn't matter how much that comparison
is like these numbers could take off
right so what was the denominator is
bigger it's got below one which is why
would I have a look at me key you can
see I'm coming from below one right I
get really really close but I never
actually cut above it exactly the same
way you can try this logic on the left
hand side put in two negative numbers
right and what you will find is you get
the exact reverse behavior your
numerator is going to be ever so
slightly bigger than the denominator why
is that these guys here are both going
to be it's going to be 10,000 or
whatever so look what happens to these
guys when X is negative 100 this is
going to be a positive thing and when X
is negative a hundred this is going to
be a negative things you've got a
slightly bigger numerator over slightly
smaller denominator that means you're
going to be approaching from above does
that make sense so again later on when
you learn calculus you can actually find
out does it turn what does it dot but
this is kind of a quick and dirty to
work way to work out well I'm trying to
decide therefore this solution okay